So, the first thing we want to do is load our launcher and on the top right hand side
here you can see launch Unreal Engine and again you can pick the version that you want
to have there.
You can go into your library and select the engine version from this tab as well if you've
not got it installed we can just click plus engine version and you can install a new version
of Unreal and you can select the drop down options from the engine version selector there.
So I'm just going to go ahead and launch Unreal Engine.
I've got 5.0.2 here but it's completely up to you which engine version you're using.
Ideally to follow along with this it would be Unreal Engine 5 but the actual 0.2 does
not matter in this instance.
So Unreal Engine will initialize and we'll just let it build and compile everything that
it needs to and then we're going to load into a project of our choosing.
So the first screen that we see here will be our recent projects.
We'll have games, film, video, live events and these are all prefabs for your project
to give you some default properties to set up inside your engine so you don't have to
do all the heavy lifting yourself.
For today's example we're going to go over to games.
I'm going to select a third person running game and we're going to keep blueprint selected
here we don't need the C++ files.
I'm going to choose the target platform as desktop.
I'm going to keep quality preset at maximum and I'm going to maybe include some starter
we want any assets to play with which are 3D meshes or any things like that.
I'll leave ray tracing on tick for now.
If you have a ray tracing enabled computer feel free to enable that but I'm just going
to call this let's call it running game.
Whatever name and convention you go for it's fine.
Generally my project would be okay but we just want to try and avoid any projects that
we're not sure what the actual project would be.
So it's always best to name it something that you intend it to be.
Project location doesn't matter too much however I would recommend having the projects if you
have an SSD installed on your computer or laptop it's always better to run Unreal Engine
projects off an SSD just because the information is accessed much faster there.
So we'll create this project and we'll let it create everything again Unreal Engine is
going to make certain assumptions for us to get us up and running faster.
We can still manipulate all these settings and we can actually change the game type from
inside the project if we decide that we no longer want it to be a third person template
we can change this inside of Unreal Engine.
However it's just much quicker time of saving of time if you start with the template that
you intend to use.
So you can see we have the engine open here.
First of all we can look around this main scene and we'll go over the UI in more detail
but I'm just going to hold my right mouse button in this viewpoint and I'm going to
press and hold right mouse button and you can see that I can look around here.
I'm going to press and hold left mouse button and I can move forwards backwards and I can
just pan around this scene.
Now I can hold left and mouse right mouse button sorry to move up and down.
So again right mouse button to look around left button to navigate through the scene
and then both mouse buttons to move up and down and you can just get yourself familiar
with this type of navigating the scene.
You can also as a quick shortcut hold right mouse button and use W, A, S and D on your
keyboard to navigate through the scene.
So if you're familiar with WASD controls generally found in PC interactive experiences you can
use those to navigate the scene as well.
So we'll go over more detail of the rest of Unreal Engine.
I'm just going to tick that off there and all we really want to do now is just check
how to load up a project and run into the game.
So I'm going to click this big green play button here.
I'm going to click play and you'll see that I'm instantly inside the game.
So I'll click into the screen and you can see that we're running around pressing W and
panning our camera using our mouse and we can press S, we can press A, we can press
D and instantly straight out of the box we've got an example running game.
No coding required just clicking a few buttons to get started.
So that's how powerful Unreal Engine can be just straight out of the box.